the type of sand used in the production
of this sandpaper is a company secret
the cameras have to keep their distance
while the machine punches discs and
sheets out of the large rolls
klingspor abrasives started making the
paper in western ukraine more than two
years ago
holland krasny had to keep production
costs down and wages here are a fraction
of what they'd be in germany
out of germany but to expand our
production
and in other countries the costs would
have been prohibitive compared to
ukraine
we started here with wage intensive
products and of course knowing that
ukraine had a lot of potential in terms
of manpower
started out on the production line
her laboratory and technical training
helped her move quickly up the ladder
now she works in quality control for the
abrasives maker
we get good in-service training here
i've been to kiev for courses in
international industrial norms i'm also
taking computer courses in excel as well
as english classes
with the help of foreign investment and
budding expertise the levi region in
western ukraine is beginning to develop
economically
the ukrainian home improvement chain
epicenter recognized the potential for
growth years ago now it has 40 stores
across the country
the german abrasives maker has young
promoters fresh out of university
selling its products to
do-it-yourselfers
epicenter also supplies construction
companies an ideal channel for roland
kashni to gain more recognition for his
products
and the home improvement centers are
hoping that that will bring in even more
business
i think they'll be steadily expanding
their product range
and will be the first to offer these
innovations we see it as a good
opportunity
the government in kiev has long
neglected the country's western regions
felikimosti the location of clingsport's
facility was no exception
during the soviet era the area's economy
was based on mining and manufacturing
mostly arms and heavy machinery
now there are many qualified specialists
looking for work and willing to travel
long distances
it's a good opportunity for foreign
investors
at some 500 euros a month klingspor's
wages are well above average for ukraine
a few times a year the director gets his
management team together for a company
lunch to build team spirit
and get some feedback
most of the workers would like a chance
to visit western europe more often and
not just for training at the parent
plant in germany
it's still difficult for ukrainians to
obtain visas for the european union and
probably will be for some time to come
they want to see what the world is like
what alternatives there are out there
i'm sure all these people would come
back they're attached to their homeland
and proud to be ukrainians
this nation has had a hard time of it
over the past century after centuries of
foreign rule it's a nation again but
only for the last 20 years the people
ought to be free to travel i'm very much
in favor of that
it's not always easy for foreign
companies to set up shop in ukraine
either
customs can be steep and there's plenty
of red tape with taxes
closer relations between the eu and
ukraine might also help cut down on
corruption
there are so many laws and regulations
that ukrainian companies don't follow
you can buy your way out when we came
here we didn't deal with bribes i don't
have a single grief
as the national currency is called in my
safe
all our transactions are cashless
through transfers and that helps ensure
that we observe the law
plans to expand the facility and almost
double the workforce up to 500 staff
from the current 300.
is hoping her next in-service training
course will come soon and that it will
take place in germany